if you don't have and this goes in maybe
into the sixth question but
if you don't have god in the public
square
the the true god let's say then you'll
have other gods
so that one way or another our society
will enshrine some
orthodoxy some god some authority and
the only question is whether it's a
it's a merciful and and loving god
or a furious one like the god of ibrahim
kindy
i think this was particularly poignant
for my liberal friends who are still
struggling with sort of shifting or
seeing what i think a new conservatism
is can you be spiritual without being
religious
because a lot of liberals say they're
spiritual but they're afraid of saying
that they're religious
and that's about 20 of americans now
identify as spiritual but not religious
and what i argue in the chapter is that
the problem with that
isn't the religiosity it's the it's the
spirituality that
um a lot of these americans do all sorts
of religious things
uh they they do hot yoga they
drink only i don't know whatever the hot
peppers and juice on fridays what have
you
those have aspects of liturgical kind of
asceticism
and self-discipline in the body but they
don't have the
shared kind of public account of
ultimate meaning
that religion brings together religion
is a combination of those kinds of
kind of ritualistic actions with some
ultimate account of ultimate meaning
and um when you have just the
ritualistic aspects you're um you're
doing it just for yourself and it's kind
of it's
it's private and there are all sorts of
things that happen in traditional
societies
that take religious rituals seriously
that you don't
access from that so i tell the chapter
through the life of
um victor and edith turner a pair of
british anthropologists
completely atheistic communist party
members
they go to africa as anthropologists to
study
tribal ritual and they notice that these
tribal rituals as silly as they may have
seen to other anthropologists
actually have this important function in
society they um
they help solve resolve what would have
otherwise been intractable conflicts
they
remind the powerful that they're
ultimate ultimately powerful only to
serve the lower
um and and and generally they kind of
provide for a a kind of humane
um society as a whole that's what ritual
did and they came ultimately when they
cam came back to britain
they were their assignments were done
they they became cast like themselves
because of what they had seen um but
you know what what they would have
looked would if they had seen
our version of ritual they would have
noticed that we have ritual but it
doesn't it's a very kind of merciless
ritual so
for example we have a kind of
penitential right
right if you say something uh
inappropriate on twitter that's
considered offensive and it runs a foul
against pc rules you kind of do a kind
what looks like a confession
i confess to my friends that i have
greatly wronged through my fault through
my fault through my most egregious
you know yeah i agree with his fault so
we have that
it doesn't have the other aspects that
make
a penitential right like that humane and
and
and full of mercy and full of
forgiveness it only has the right and
it's kind of brutal
how damaging do you think it was that in
the last year and a half that people
were locked out of going to church and
and to temple i mean the fact that they
could do some of the stuff privately
obviously but could not have
that public portion of this i mean i
tried it i i
personally tried going to internet mass
and it just isn't the same i mean
the mass especially has a kind of
embodied element as catholics believe
that
um uh you know the the lord makes
himself literally present in
in the form of bread and wine uh the end
you know
virtually it doesn't quite work the same
um
and um no i mean i think it was a great
um failure on the part of
religious leaders across the nominations
and faith to be honest
but they so readily acquiesced um to
to these restrictions
and then and kept at it long after it
became clear that
uh you know that there are other risks
to be worried about
such as people falling away from faith
yeah although interestingly i think that
i'm sensing more and more people coming
back to faith now partly because of all
of this
the endless chaos of all this plus you
the endless chaos of all of this i think
has actually led
people back in a way i don't know that
it'll be exactly in the
in the way that you would want it to be
or that i would want it to be but i do
sense some sort of spiritual awakening
right now is that true i mean i i
haven't seen the numbers i mean i
i had to get i don't know the number
well if you look at the numbers they'll
always tell you that there's more
atheists now than ever before and really
you know organized religion
is on the downfall but i do sense
something else because the
the secular world went so out of control
there's nothing like mortality to remind
people of the last things and so
i hope so yeah sure question five does
god
respect you i think this will
uh this is a question where any number
of people will
uh object if they think that look um
my human dignity is just founded in my
my being human my being my rights um
but i argue in the chapter that if you
don't think that the human being has
some special origin and some special
destiny
then why wouldn't you acquiesce to all
sorts of political horrors that
for example disfigure the 20th century
because human beings are just the
product of uh you know evolutionary
development and
and no different from other animals or
so you know why not have
mass atrocities and so forth um
so i i argue that a lot of people today
who
clamor for uh social justice
uh reject religion out of hand because
they think it's just a source of
oppression but i argue that
the biblical faith because of the
emphasis in potent on on the human
person as uniquely dignified as
as made in the image of god as genesis
tells us
it's a bulwark against all sorts of uh
political injustices
and that i mean yeah i mean that's it
seems an obvious point to me but i know
lots of people disagree
yeah what about how religious or i guess
cult-like would be the better
explanation the the social justice
warriors have become
do you disconnect that from god or do
you think these things are all tied
together
well it just tells me that if if you if
you don't have
and this goes in maybe into the sixth
question but if you don't have god in
the public square
the true god let's say then you'll have
other gods
so that one way or another our society
will enshrine some
orthodoxy some god some authority and
the only question is whether it's a
it's a merciful and and loving god
or a furious one like the god of ibrahim
kindy
right so that is really question six
which is does god need politics you
could have also said does does politics
need god right yeah i mean i i
god doesn't need anything the
theologians would tell us and they're
right because
you know he's a supreme being but um i
argue that the god of the bible um in
entering human history
wants to transfigure not just our
private lives
but also our public lives so our cities
also want to
he wants to transfigure them and that
historically
societies have always had as i said
some uh some altar in the public square
and so the only question is which one
and and this is my kind of most
controversial
argument it's it's what makes me get
called a theocratic
the new york times but
but it just seems obvious to me that
especially in the past two years or so
um when it's become so clear that the
loss of the
you know judeo-christian orthodoxy
whatever you want to call it
hasn't resulted in a neutral public
square it's
it's just empowered um kind of crazy
orthodoxies that
the uh demand that you um
bow before them right well that's why i
thought this chapter was so interesting
because i came
at all of this from a different
political perspective than you
and yet i've come to the same conclusion
which is that without god or some
organizing factor and we can
whittle that down how we may this is
what you get
the thing that we have right now where
we're debating biological differences
between men and women as if
they don't exist that's what you get at
the end
right right and so i i just think
there's no situation
in which you can say well i believe that
there are
two sexes a man and woman as genetics
and and genesis tell us and someone else
thinks there are 135
uh genders one of those will prevail
and so um i think that
a lot of conservatives people on my side
of the divide really
but also some liberals too in fact a lot
of liberals
relinquish their responsibility to say
no no there is truth
about the about certain things we can be
absolutely certain about and
and and your interior
um misperception doesn't amount to truth
why do you think so many people folded
when it comes to issues like this
just folded so quickly let's say
yeah i mean i think there is a kind of
of of
abnormalism built into our philosophy
nominalism is this idea that that
um it's very old it comes comes to us
from the medieval
age basically that certain theologians
said look
the world what we see is just the things
in it are too different to allow any
kind of essential classification
now none of them would have gotten to
gender ideology i mean it would have
been
bonkers to them but you take that idea
far enough and you're like well
what does it really mean to be a man and
what does it really mean to be a moment
i know what i am
but i can't generalize about that to
everyone else
um so that that's the kind of
philosophical root of it and then
i think there's a a more basic level
um americans just just want to be nice
and so if someone
cries out and says well i'm conflicted
about who i am
i might be something other than what
nature or my body tells me
you want to respect that you kind of
want to you want to embrace them
but um sometimes that that
yearning to embrace and be nice can
actually be really
deadly and harmful if you're looking for
more honest and thoughtful conversations
about spirituality instead of non-stop
yelling check out our spirituality
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics check
out our full episode playlist they're
all right over here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell